my gosh it's like a dream come true I
mean especially in this day and age like
to be at season three it's amazing so
excited what are fans gonna I mean we've
seen some previews but what can fans
expect for season three oh what'd you
take you always put it on me okay then
I'll know it's okay um so obviously we
all know where I am at my relationship
right now and this season you're gonna
see you're gonna see the ups and downs
of John and I trying to make it to the
altar and everything that happened I
think that's the biggest question right
now is why and what and I feel like
that's all gonna be answered this season
I think everyone has their own little
speculation and something that's truly
amazing is we have the first ever
women's Royal Rumble at WWE and Bree and
I make a comeback there and it was just
so amazing such an honor
yeah and it was really cool too because
it was my first match back after giving
birth to birdie and I think for me the
neat thing that the audience will see
especially moms is they'll relate to
kind of my journey getting back into the
ring you know everything's different the
way I move in the ring to you know my
body image and all these things I'm
trying to fight but the same time I'm
trying to breastfeed and like just make
mom life work so I think moms are really
gonna connect with me this season
because they're just really gonna see me
in every episode balancing career and
mom life and my husband and us trying to
make time for each other so it's tough
you're busy women but it's good to be
busy in it so I want to ask obviously
you mentioned you know we're gonna see
what's gonna happen with the
relationship in this season how much
tougher is it to deal with this I know
everybody is going to see this um it's
it's tough it makes it a lot harder it
makes it like you you know breakups suck
this makes it like the ultimate like
we're Spray Cup ever but it's uh am I
gonna sell us my train of thought but
there's no secrets in reality television
like how you can't keep a secret like
there's cameras follow me well you know
we have to relive it and I think that's
what makes it difficult is you have
you it's like I have to relive this
breakup all over again when it airs but
I think because it's been such a media
frenzy and everyone is happy and like
well this is what happened or this is it
or jonghwan in today's show and talking
about it for a long time which is so
weird can I just say I mean I was just
like kind of taken aback I'm like he's
doing this on national TV right thing is
and we we are in communication and it
just makes it a lot harder but I think
that's what makes me so much more
excited from total Bella's to premiere
this Sunday is because you're just
finally gonna see the journey of word
unfolds and where the Downs start to
happen and then the speculations are
gonna go away and the judgment and
people thinking like they're doing this
for the show or this and whatever it is
and I think that's what makes it really
excited for this season to come out
because after being here this week I'm
just like oh my gosh yeah it's been
tough it's a lot it's a lot to deal with
and even just today right before I came
in here I googled your name as you
should and it's like oh this is all for
press this is all fake and I'm like I'm
like what do you say to people who
actually think you're doing this for
press it's I think sometimes people
don't realize how you could affect them
it's kind of like when we try to talk to
like cyber bullies yeah and tell them
like you have no idea how you're
affecting people it's I'm a human being
I'm a human being that literally went
through a breakup and everyone's been
through a breakup and think of how we
feel so mine is just been blown up and
then people all sort of telling me I'm
faking it so you're now saying that my
heartache is fake and that makes it even
harder it's just like what can I do
right and that's just really really
tough which people would have thought
you know me giving birth was fake good I
never got that well what I do love and I
was watching a clip and you are just
it's so great you have a sister first of
all I have a sister who I love and you
know I'm very close with but you have a
sister who tells it like it is right you
serious you tell it like it is and I
mean you probably hate it at times right
it's the worst I know like you never
lets me just like you know what the
worst part is
when she's really quiet I know I'm right
but sometimes I wish you'd just like
you're right I'm kind but at least I'm
quiet then you know what's it like
living together again now is that well I
saw that I saw that why are you I cook
for you I clean for you you had me
sleeping on a pullout bed you can buy a
bed just move my couch see how rude that
is I talk about like getting an
apartment or a condo she's like oh how
dare you're gonna leave me and I'm like
I know go from one house with rules in
the next house I be on my own for like a
minute I just zero I want what rules
you're kind of bossy and you like demand
things for me bossy is good sometimes no
yeah I just feel like I'm back in high
school like with a mom I'm like yeah let
me guess I have a curfew too I haven't
even begun to go out I can't even
imagine the day yeah huh
I mean if you're not gonna be sitting on
the couch with like grumpy faces like
yeah where is Matt by 9 p.m.
make sure to Eber